this area here what running around that
ocean ocean let's that's very general
that's kind of dive deeper was it to do
with the ocean so like like our know
that these spheres or the Marianas
Trench wasn't in no not one that I've
said though algae ocean algae good
suggestion yeah good suggestion
okay um front of the room what's on here
one outcome variable is that micropenis
thank you very much not sure if it's a
suggestion or a heckles very hard to
tell
don't if i'm really showing in these
transom ocean algae micropenis and i
love that you had that prepared that was
lovely
at the back someone said something hula
hoop yeah okay and what do you say the
falklands hula hooping in the falklands
will combine them for some delightful
thing for Americans the Falklands are a
set of islands off of Arjun
Henry Hoover you sound so in love that
I'm now I'm thinking you might be one of
those women who like marry objects and
you're like the Eiffel Tower the Leaning
Tower of Pisa and this is my husband
Henry mm-hmm
it's Henry Hoover a thing in America do
you guys have them okay listen there's
some disagreement it's an
anthropomorphize tuba if you must know
so Henry Hoover hula-hooping in the
Falklands algae micropenis you guys you
get the last suggestion what's gonna be
polka and what was that mummification
cool I kinda prefer that to poker sorry
about that
hey hey how do you get the brain out of
her body your mother fine you cut poker
stick up its notes there you go
i'ma put on for you what were you saying
it's a good question I'm glad it came
after the five stipulated suggestions
we'll never find out
we'll never fullness maybe we will okay
this then read I've given them a beat in
the back is that what are you able to
play along to that at the end of it or
is that gonna be not this lovely people
of the Comedy Cellar little thing called
a freestyle rap there's a rap made on
the spot based entirely on suggestions
do the once again work algae ocean algae
hula-hooping in the Falklands micropenis
mummification and was on Henry Hoover
and don't worry it won't be anyone knows
atrociously embarrassingly bad as you're
expecting and frankly educate
middle-class white boy to be so sweet
drop that feet good sir and let's have
some fun time I caught you a spooky beat
for Halloween guys this is just for
tonight I was like oh we want some
spookiness it's got some nice bass as
well
it's gonna get
your pulse is thrumming and drumming
it's gonna be good yeah if you don't
like the rap don't tell me drown you
deep in the ocean among the out leads
and now eat you up like a whale with the
baleen they use it as a filter help to
clean all the water mixed with bacteria
if you like algae think it's inferior to
any of the thing causing all the
commotion we know algae is the center of
the ocean cycle of life without it we
might die - producing lots of oxygen
that flows into the sky force and
persist in the ocean cells and with the
temperature rising and the ocean swells
algebra taking over you soon all the
governments returning the green not blue
need to ask the question or why why is
the ocean blue because it reflects the
sky when I think back you know I'm
really gonna need it succeeded mummify
embodies you need you're not an each
I've got all of the knowledge here tools
I put a coat hanger up the body's
nostrils wiggle it around I pull out the
brain I pop it in the canopic jar and
then I just shaved all of the legs are
waxing and then I lick my lips for
formaldehyde and then apply strips often
I will put the evil eye inside the body
of the Pharaoh the recently died and
then I killed off its slaves all them in
the room I buried them with fair road
deep inside the tomb
I say get in there slaves you should all
follow us Pharaohs got a coffin we call
that [ __ ] a sarcophagus
Egyptology I study it hard I was working
and then I'm on my guard like a British
soldier in the 1980s you don't hear
about the Falklands late
the lady in charge was Maggie Thatcher
she's dead now that's all I'll say
[ __ ] her and bathe in it how well we
know the sons headlines think the
Belgrano gotcha a reference the only
Brits will understand if you're
Argentinian you don't call it the
Falklands you call it malvinas you think
that your own them you [ __ ] dope take
my penis and blow them where's your
penis Chris we can't seem to find it
it's a micro penis sorry err I will
define it I went for the doctor I've got
my thrilled when I learned he could
prescribe the enlargement pills
it grew who from a molehill into a
mountain no longer micro penis this life
the Trevi fountains it's white and its
views frequently I make a mess on the
floor [ __ ] mum sees I need to clean it
up I need to improve there so I move all
the seminal fluid out with the hooba now
people say it looks so odd that Henry
Hoover's long nose is giving me a job on
the blow it's flexible it follows me
around he trundles he trundles you hear
that sound he's not a Dyson that's a
nice one it tries to make a much
powerful suction with the vacuum suck
you Mammon suction what was the
destruction of the Byzantine Empire I
love my instruction was it wrong
that's a question that I'm glad I can't
answer the suggestion was too late
you're like ah I'm really hopeful we'll
talk about the sack of Constantinople
but [ __ ] that we know the city was
plundered for the last time early mid 14
hundreds the Byzantine they were like
you and whose army
there we go slice of the veal a salami
[Applause]
[Music]